in other cases
like one that i like to talk like to
think about is
or like to point out as an example is is
free will and determinism
it's much less of a theorem
and more more a uh more
a a kind of uh
way of thinking about things that i
think is
uh reassuring and
avoids uh a lot of unnecessary
quarreling and confusion the quarreling
i'm okay with
and the confusion i'm okay with i mean
people debate about difficult ideas
but the the question is whether it could
be almost
a fundamental truth i think it is a
fundamental truth
free will is both an illusion
and not yes i think that's correct and i
lo there's a reason why people say
quantum mechanics
is weird and complementarity is
is is a big part of that you know
to say that the our actual whole world
is weird
the whole hierarchy of the universe is
weird in this
kind of particular way and
it's it's quite profound but it's also
um
humbling because it's like
we're never going to be on sturdy ground
in the way that humans
like to be it's like you have to embrace
that uh
well this this this whole thing is is a
like unsteady mess it's one of it's one
of many
lessons in humility that that we
uh run into in profound understanding of
the world
i mean uh the copernican revolution was
one
that's that the earth is not the center
of the universe
uh darwinian evolution is another that
uh
humans are not the pinnacle of uh
of uh you know of god's creation
uh the the uh and
the apparent
result of uh uh deep understanding of
physical reality that
the mind emerges from matter and human
there's you know
there's there's no uh no call
on special life forces or souls uh
these are all lessons in humility and
i actually find complementarity
a uh a liberating concept
it's it's uh okay you know yeah it is in
a way
uh that is what i remember there's a
story about dr johnson and he's talking
with boswell
and boswell was they were discussing a
sermon that they both
both heard and the the sort of
culmination of
of the sermon was the the speaker saying
i accept the universe
and dr johnson said well he damn well
better
and and there's a certain uh there's a
certain joy in accepting the universe
because it's mind expanding and
[Music]
you know and to me complementarity
also suggests tolerance
suggests opportunities for understanding
different different understanding things
in different ways that add
uh add to rather than
detract from uh understanding
so uh i think it's it's an up it's an
opportunity for mind expansion
and demanding that there's only one way
that
to think about things can be very
limiting
on the freewill one that's a trippy one
though to think like i am
the decider of my own actions and at the
same time i'm not
is uh it is tricky to think about but
it's
there seems to be some kind of profound
truth in that i get
well i think it is tied up it will turn
out to be tied up when we understand
things better
with these issues of self-awareness and
i think so
and where we get what what we perceive
as making choices what does that really
mean
and what's going on under the hood and
but i'm i'm speculating about a future
understanding that's not in place
but at present your sense there will
always be uh
like as you dig into the self-awareness
thing there'll always
be some places where complementarity is
going to show up oh definitely
yeah i mean there will be uh
how should i say there'll be kind of a
god's eye view
which sees everything that's going on
in the computer or the the brain and
then there's the brain's own view
or the or the the central processor or
whatever it is that's the what we call
the the
the the self the consciousness that's
all only aware of a very small part of
it
and those are very different those are
the the
so uh the god's eye view can be
deterministic
while the the the self view
sees free will and that's i i'm pretty
sure that's how it's going to work out
actually and but as it as it stands free
will
is a concept that we definitely at least
i feel
i definitely experience i can choose to
do one thing than another
and other people i think are
sufficiently similar to me that i
i trust that they feel the same way
and it's an essential concept in
psychology and law
and so forth but uh
at the same time i think that mind
emerges from matter
and that there's an alternative
description of matter that's
up to subtleties about quantum mechanics
which i don't think are relevant here
really is deterministic
you